okay good afternoon everybody
welcome to the March meeting of the
cabinets and we will start when I've got
my voice back with apologies for absence
apologies to receive from counselor
organ and from counselor brain
disclosures of interest castle law
Thank You chair and item deine chairman
which is oddly co-op site I have a
personal interest in that I've been
involved in trying to promote this or
development I have no particular
interest on quite happy to delay in the
room okay you're just declaring a
personal interest council server Thank
You Cameron I think all councillors are
in cabinet received a letter from our
some villages Association we have an
addition of had a phone call from
residents councillor Richard thank you
chair in addition to the letters
referred to by other members I've had a
list long enough to not go through now
but from Teddington from a number of
consul teas given this falls under my
portfolio I think that's expected anyway
so I will remain so we can blame
councillor Ralph
okay
right so we've all finished I also have
had a long list of representations over
the transport strategy okay let's move
on to item 3 which is the minutes of our
last meeting the meeting was held on the
12th of February and those minutes were
published as a notice of decision and
are therefore reproduced for endorsement
today
do I have your agreement that there are
true record of the proceedings that day
agree great thank you
I'll sign those some stage during the
meeting now this is a slightly unusual
meeting in that normally about the first
five items on the cabinet I have to
introduce his portfolio holder I've been
relieved of that problem today so I'm
going to move on to the first item item
for stratford-upon-avon area transport
strategy and leave the introduction to
councillor Richards thank you very much
general I don't say too much at this
point but I do want to reserve a rise to
speak again later on once we've had
representations from members the public
and members of the cabinet you could
have that right that's very kind of you
that reserve so the strap not even
transport strategy as drafted and
provided within the report and will form
the viewers for it to form part of the
Warwickshire local transport planner w
LT P 2011 2026
it is a Warwickshire government plan not
a Stratford on Ivan covered plan however
I felt it was very holder firm for
structure I feel it is important that we
have knifeman debate both that cabinet
and particularly
so this is one of my significant pieces
of work that will affect this town and I
think it's important we have that
opportunity so the reason for the
recommendations as they're laid out so
the reason one for recommendation one as
I've said is this is this forms part of
the warwickshire of group of plans
rather than ours in order for us to
fully debate and endorse this we must
include it as part of our concert our
Constitution in order to be able to have
that endorsement and a recommendation to
is purely and simply I'm seeking for
cabinets approval for the transport
strategy to go to full council be
debated and the recommendation for full
council to endorse I will leave it at
that first time being from a chair but I
said I'd like to speak again nature for
quiet I have one public speaker who was
registered to speak for that mr. Howard
Blessington so I'm going to invite him
to come up to a microphone so the
recording equipment can pick him up okay
mr. Blessington you have three minutes
to address us in now my name is Howard
Blessington and I speak on behalf of
three residence groups in South East
Stratford the ABA the TV IRA and cause
I'm a former transportation planning
director of the world's largest firm of
civil and transportation engineers I'm a
former transportation planning director
of the world's largest firm of civil and
transportation engineers so I speak as
someone who has both knowledge and
experience unfortunately the current
transport strategy is one of the worst
pieces of technical work I've ever seen
there is no discernible technical
process no specification or discussion
of outcomes which it will deliver no
presentation of impacts and no
discussion of risks arising from any
proposed measures the worst example of
these deficiencies is with respect to
the eastern relief Road as recently
expressed by John degan chair of the
town transport group and former director
of
or account counsel in the case of a
possible eerr we are very concerned that
no information is provided on where it
will go what outcomes it will deliver or
what impacts it will have since the
council's also concede that it is not
required to deliver the core strategy it
should not be included in the transport
strategy at this stage even to protect
the possibility that there might be a
need at that later stage to float an
inner are now would simply risk
unnecessary speculative development
pressure in this area which was firmly
rejected through a public referendum in
2014 on strategic housing allocations
should the council however remain
unmoved in the face of informed
technical opposition I would offer two
further considerations which I hope will
inform judgments being made today
although three times as many people
objected to the proposed measures which
included the RR I supported it the
objection would probably have been even
greater but for the intervention of the
leader of Warwickshire County Council
who during the consultation period
declared to 200 people in a public
meeting in sitting ttan her amazement
that the eastern relief wrote if it
included been in the package of measures
and that as far as walker county council
was concerned it had no place in the
strategy I know many people who didn't
object based on her assurances the
second point if major development of say
three to three and a half thousand
houses were to be approved as a direct
result of this road this would generate
approximately 20,000 additional trips
per day per day of the existing road
network around Stratford I'm doing for
all time any other improvements which
might arise from the strategy in summary
it will be a green light for unwanted
development and from a transport
perspective it will be exactly the wrong
thing to do though I'm no expert in
these matters I understand from others
that for these reasons alone the council
may be exposing itself to the
possibility of a crowdfunded judicial
review on behalf of those I've been
asked to represent we request simply
that the council remove the eerr from
the strategy until the appropriate
technical work has been completed and
share
local communities thank you very much
the opportunity to spoon okay is it mr.
Blessington you represent the over some
villages Association and the tootington
village residents Association and cause
so that's basically Loxley ro
Cheddington Road Banbury Road and the
reason I didn't realize there was so
many I've had communications with a chap
called Richard Hyde I know yes and
indeed he used to be a member of this
council what he also lived exactly where
he does now as I understand that but
however he's been in contact with me and
but the the issue is are you just
objecting to the presence of the eastern
relief Road or does your objection go
wider than that
my objection goes much wider to the
strategy as a whole although I believe
there are good things in the strategy I
believe that the document as presented
to the public gives no information on
the outcomes which which will be
achieved it gives no diagrams it gives
no numbers that gives no tables it
describes no impacts but the worst
example is the eastern the leaf road
which is why in the space of three
minutes I've focused very specifically
on that because that's where I believe
the greatest risk is not just to south
of Stratford but to the whole district
but once we have an extra 20,000 trips
per day on our network does the various
organizations you represent given that
only a Monday last week the government
announced that the National targets for
housing have got to rise to 300,000 a
year that will inevitably increase the
demand on Stratford or Stratford on Avon
district so did you imagine that we
could avoid the consequences of the
request no but I think that has to go
through a formal planning process I
think the problem with the eastern
relief road is that it
it's a planning process through the back
door
once that Eastern relief road goes in
the development will inevitably follow
and if that in that development
inevitably follows then the benefits of
the eastern relief road should be
described in terms of not just the road
that the road and the development what
will be the impact on Stratford and the
impact on Stratford will be that it will
grind to a halt that's that is my
professional opinion and there is no
incidentally there is no information in
any of the documentation just to say
otherwise
because there is no information in any
of the documents a bandeau want to ask a
question of mr. Blessington no okay
thank you so much yes right any members
of the cabinet want to speak now
now you could speak later yeah right
counts the roll file take next you put
your hand up
[Music]
forgive me I'm gonna sit very slowly
because I'm still not very well I've
come here to support the residence of
Alveston Teddington and my entire panty
water I also ask that the Easter relief
Road is removed from the transport
strategy but better the transports trust
you is a is a wish list and at worst
it's a wish list and that's exactly what
it is there's no meter we're on the
bones of any of the proposals on a list
and in particular
Thiessen relief Road is just really
quite it's a joke what what is
interesting is that I spoke only two
weeks ago three weeks ago to counselor
is he circum and I asked her what her
feelings were about these two relief
Road being part of the transport
strategy and her response was over my
dead body will this be included in the
transport strategy now it might be that
you have had subsequent conversations
but she is she has said that she will
support me when I speak at County
Council about asking for the eastern
leaf road to be removed from the
transport strategy I also have here
which is really rather interesting sorry
on page 15 3.6 of this of your report it
says here that the draft transport the
draft strategy proposed to
da-da-da-da-da traffic modeling has
shown that an Eastern reliever had
delivered in addition to a full western
relief road another transport mitigation
identified through the co strategy
process would further reduce congestion
and stratford-upon-avon I have here an
email from the into orchid now I know
Linda isn't
and I'm sure she won't mind me quoting a
small better female she wrote to
arrested where she said that the eastern
relief road has failed the test of the
core strategy and is not in the
council's core strategy which has been
through all the hurdles and has been
endorsed by the Planning Inspectorate
she spoke at the meeting which I
organized for 200 people at football
club she spoke against the eastern
relief Road now I'm obviously clearly
something is is is not being transported
if you like to one of your cabinet
members because counseling into organ
clearly states but it's not part of the
core strategy and that it doesn't meet
all the tests however it states here
that it is a part of the cost strategy
and it has been identified so I'd like
some clarification around that I also
would like very much that this Eastern
relief Road is removed from the
transport strategy which goes on till
2026 and is then considered further when
a new course strategy is identified from
twenty thirty one omelets thank you okay
thank you um just a mere Peter
counts our role this document has been
produced or co-authored or largely
authored by the County Council now
you'll remember the County Council for
the same area Stratford as you represent
on this council so you mentioned the
leader I believe who said this shouldn't
be in there but effectively it is in
there well eventually
however have been happening with peace
gossip you'll jump in my question I was
going to sort of ask what
representations you've made to the
Cancer Council because we have to have a
document that is similar we can't agree
different documents and have a policy at
meetings along with Jennifer Ashley with
with Benson and the other one whose name
has just been out of my head Stephen
Rumble and I am on the town transport
group and I'm party to the letter that
was sent to say that the Easter relief
road should not be included so I have
represented it represented my
constituents as well as I can do and I
have also spoken to the leader of the
County Council it also says that she
doesn't think it should be in the
transport strategy I personally could
imagine why residents of ours that are
concerned about the recently to have the
simple reason they're right when they
argued that it's put in there as a
notional proposal without the detail or
the evidence to go with it but
effectively what equally I'm concerned
about is this if we're going to have a
lot more housing and that's going to
generate considerably more traffic we've
got to have the highway infrastructure
to take that traffic so where do you
propose it should go well so is that our
job to find out well yeah you you tell
me there's nothing you know the you
can't stick it down boundary laid and
people telling us
it just is not you that you know once
once housing has been identified in the
next core plan that's the time to
actually look at a route a proper route
of these some relief Road
it can't be discussed now there's
nothing there there's no meet around the
bones where's it going to go where is it
going to go it should not be in there
we've got eight years grace just leave
it out of the plan out of the transport
strategy okay
Thank You counselor all right counselor
as far as I can see apps that you know
cost things now I'd like to make points
on four areas the first of which besides
being mentioned in this plan and to be
fair that strategy is developed but if
you remember the Birmingham overspill
report that's just come out from GL
Hearn hmm identifies Southie to
Stratford as one of the potential sites
although it ruled it out and said no
further exploration of that discount
my concern is forward to say this is
clearly where we should go without
either chairman well quite clearly the
GFL report identified a new settlement
at Earls word as the best option
development well I agree with hot George
as well but there's no doubt about it
that is the one that they said should be
coming forward I had all the options in
this district that's someone they say
should be carried forward for further
investigation so let's see where that
goes Joe right second point
railway reinstatement you'll be aware
but this is gradually moving towards a
supportive position on the honey borne
Stratford link something which I'm
strongly opposed to no the consultant's
report chairman that several years ago
looked at that reinstatement came up
with a then costing of a hundred million
pounds capital and said that it would
need revenue support forevermore
it would never pay its way no the
problem with including it in this German
is I can see the next state we're going
for would be a grip for study and if you
remember when we applied to the length
of funds for that group for study we
costed it a half a million pounds
frankly chairman what we should be doing
if anything is asking for a refresh of
the previous consultants report to see
if anything has significantly changed
from an they say it was impractical and
would not pay for itself let us forget
the idea of paying half a million pounds
that council taxpayers money on
something which on the face of it looks
completely unworkable third point German
bus station page 28 again the County
Council report on the bus station made
it quite clear there was only one viable
position for a bus station in Stratford
and that was the Windsor Street car park
then this council as you're well aware
granted an option to a developer to
knock that down
Jimmy that appears they don't know where
that development and I think it's going
we've grasped that metal center data
buffer this is not moving forward unless
you can produce something within the
limited time scale we are going to
cancel option which we have the right to
do then chairman that would be the place
to look to see if we can it's on page 20
I believe it's obvious I know that the
junction was it's the relevant Southwest
relief Road is the obvious place to put
it chairman and I believe this report
should reflect that thank you
the reason the land by Waitrose was lost
was because nobody came forward with a
feasible proposition within the
three-year period that the developer was
obliged to hold it so let's not be a
little bit careless with our words here
I'd also like to comment so I've got to
bring Council of Barnes in next because
he's been waiting to speak
I imagine counselor a concern or want to
challenge you over the building of a new
settlement in the Greenbelt in URLs
would
I think counsel Atkins has said the
right thing that it is not planning
policy and what the Hearn report says is
not shall we build this new estate new
development but would you like to
consider including it when you reverse
your core strategy those of us that
watch country file last night would have
had spotted a report on councils that
have all haven't got a local plan right
and it also counted with something that
never comes out of the planning
inspector its website that you loved to
quote at us or used to and that is those
that have a local plan that is more than
five years old
we don't houses 18 months old as members
are well aware and therefore a review is
some way off but effectively this is
where some situations are vulnerable and
I think I have to make these comments in
case you make any stray comment mr.
councillor Morse that I allow the media
to think differently but effectively
we've already issued a press release
this council saying how we would defend
the greenbelt of those would and
everywhere else the Greenbelt exists
around here tooth-and-nail right council
Barnes please come forward to a
microphone I'm sorry to keep you waiting
oh I came to compliment you on page 39
point is that the franchise for gwr
includes a loop change at Oxford a loop
change at Wooster and a single track to
the racecourse
along the Greenway which will be
environmentally friendly still support
the green mate and me and my cycle and
many others 800,000 people that use it
to keep fit so all I'm saying is I
support page 39 I won't speak on roads
because they're a bit of a mismatch all
I can say is that to prepare is
cancelled the portfolio holder
how big is Baker you know it's not
bother taking
I I got them looking while I was talking
which was the idea all I can say is on
the roads into the portfolio hold up
myself the police and the first
cancer-specific chambers without a very
good meeting and have moved forward
substantially on the be for said fee too
but as far as I'm concerned the rail
link to the Fe racecourse is
environmentally good and we need to
perform okay now so Jefferson thank you
later
first I would actually like to
compliment
councillor Richard in yourself for
actually enabling is to have a debate on
this issue because I gather it need not
have come to either cabinet or Council
so I think it is extremely worthwhile
that this document is aired and debated
very thoroughly having said that my view
on the document as published is there is
a lack of clarity the rigour and depth
of analysis in my view is lacking the
context contextualization to the
specific needs and challenges of
stratford-upon-avon is missing there's a
lack of consideration of impact and I
would question its credibility I think I
will leave it there later because if it
is going to be discussed at Council and
they will say more at Council
because it with the prongs you've just
had like I mean it would be revised
before it reaches Council
right sorry counselor house thank you
very much this stiff come before our see
but our last meeting basically what was
said about it was that the plan of
action is designed to achieve delay in
this particular report didn't seem to
meet that there seemed to be no it was a
long time in preparation there's nothing
really news in it no evidence is
supplied in detail so it's lacking in
detail and this is a joint report
between us unwarranted kind of counsel
are we empowered therefore to pass a
decision by this council that we don't
accept this report and we would like it
revisited and rewritten in view of the
intense debate and discussion and
opposition to much of its contents that
sounds like a direct question to me
right okay
yes sure I will just comment and then
I'll hand over to you the the issue is
councilor house that we have a document
which has been present prepared in
consultation with each other
we know that therefore there are people
around this table that are wanting to to
comment on things I would say mostly the
County Council because they are the
Transport Authority can actually adopt
what they wish we have a choice as to
whether or not we effectively attempt to
influence of that choice or that
decision and that has been intimated the
purpose of today's exercise is to get it
into the system to get it onto the
council agenda for the 24th of April
that's when any decision will be made
and I was actually fiddling with my
phone sorry looking for a form of words
that had drafted
which meant that we effectively passed
it on today rather than Dorsett however
you chair the scrutiny committee
counselor house and I know you had a
long debate last week have we got any
opportunity to get any feedback from
that unfortunately we didn't have time
to go into any route of detailed
discussions around it so it was
impossible in the time that we were
allocated for us to scrutinize it
thoroughly right I'll hand over to
councillor Richards now who'll probably
summarize a number of points that have
been made can someone's to go first
that's fine oh yeah when I looked at
this I thought and scratched my head I
said I'm sure I've seen something of
this nature in the past which is
basically a lot of statements but no
structured strategy on how to get to the
objective that in management terms I
find the problem here let alone the
factors which have been mentioned by
residents and I looked at that for 2002
2003 2005 2011 very very similar
actually with without any doubt and some
important things have been mentioned the
you know 861 success of secured an
external funding there's no mention of
the amount ambitions are being expressed
we've no idea just whether or not the
funding is there or is not that to me is
a fundamental error in the management of
the situation page 33 require at least
one further river crossing I mean one
river crossing will be enough I would
have thought in financial terms one
other there's no justification no
rationale no reasoning behind that
statement at all I think also there's a
very important one which again is a
sentence
the ex-mp Oh an aspiration to improve
rail connectivity
there's nothing mentioned that what what
will it do and if that is important
which I believe it is and if I compare
it with Parkway as on the County Council
when we had to have a site visit about
its of their prospect and we had a good
number of residents complaining but with
Parkway since it was opened you've had
the provision of a car park a second car
park a third car park you've now got a
multi-storey Park car park it is so
important yet there is no recognition of
what that can do where it will go and
everything else to do with it
it is a you know a major necessity I
believe without any doubt and I just
look at it and I think well there's a
lot of statements made how are we going
to get there now you have mentioned
chairman about the relationship with
water to County Council how that will
evolve when we hear that the leader has
said over my dead body I don't know if
she's got dictatorial responsibility or
trances but that is a major sort of
criticism of the report to me it's a bit
of a wish list in many ways but there's
no structured substance to it and how
are we going to get there there's a lot
of money involved without any doubt and
there are many gaps I won't go over any
of the others because I think there have
been explained but to me it's you know
it's nothing more than a few ideas which
have not been thought through and
measured and quantified and really
tested thanks Jo
Thank You chairman there's there's a lot
that's been raised and attempt to cover
at all points I think I've written them
all down and I'm gonna try and structure
it in some form of order if I can my
first point about the leader of the
County Council I can't speak for the
leader she is not here to speak for
herself so I don't think we can really
comment on her view safe to say that had
the leader if the leader were to
influence the inclusion of the Eastern
relief road I believe she would have
done so before this was made the draft
was made public on the 15th of December
we will find out into your course when
this is voted through or auditory
debated and then voted on at the county
council but we can't make a comment on
that now and I don't think we should be
in relation to the evidence Council Rolf
referred to 0.3 point six in the report
and whether or not the eastern relief
road is part of the core strategy we all
know these relief road is not included
in the core strategy what is included in
there is that Kim's report that details
the evidence that went where's boast at
both an eastern and Southwest relief
Road that evidence and that is included
in the supporting consultation document
and linked through the main document
very clearly does identify that the
optimum solution to Stratford's
transport problems requires both a
Southwest and an Eastern relief Road in
terms of housing they'll to talk about
housing the delivery of future housing
this is not a discussion on planning
this is not a discussion on the delivery
of housing this is about future
transport and transport links
infrastructure related to transport not
housing so I don't think that should be
entering the debate at this time so now
going on to comments particularly seemed
to be focused on whether there was
appropriate detail included in this
strategy if you look at page two of the
actual strategy its page 23 of our
report
you will clearly see this is the first
page introducing the strategy and
outlining what it is seeking to achieve
it clearly shows that they're seeking to
identify general principles that need to
underlie the future development of the
towns transport network it goes on to
say that it's the transporter naturally
is there to support the achievements and
vision of the neighborhood development
plan by providing a framework for
maintaining and improving the transport
network over the next 15 years the key
words their principles and framework
that is the crux of a strategy not
detail not how the full detail on how
comes after we have established the
principles and framework and I believe
the support for those principles in
framework are included in that strategy
in the document and within the
consultation report what it allows us to
do is to go and seek funding in order to
be able to fully explore all
possibilities for delivery of the
infrastructure contained within this
report without it we do not have the
facility to go and seek funding for
things like bus depots relief roads
improvements to the towns and car
parking that sort of thing we need
something in order to be able to do that
the detail of which as I've said before
will come after it is well recognized
that Stratford Stratford has a transport
problem a a serious traffic problem that
is why we have come to work on this
strategy it started three four years ago
with Nadeem zaharie's work at the
traffic summits this is the result of
that it has taken into consideration all
the problems and issues that have been
raised by Stratford it's interesting to
note that 50 years of the held run a 50
years ago today segment or certainly
used to and I picked up in that some
time ago that 50 years ago at that point
an Eastern relief road had not only been
commissioned but shown to be sound and
had funding but of course at that point
it was a decision was made either by
Stratford I think it was Stratford town
council rather than stroke formation it
was
sighs traffic cooperation Oh your
knowledge is far out reaching my hands
Jim thank you can servants at that point
a decision was made by the traffic
corporation not to do that now if it was
required then to suggest it's not
required now I find beggars belief
particularly given we have even more
housing even more people and more
reliance on I particularly on a motor
car this is a problem we've taken action
this gives us something to actually move
forward with and seek further detail on
individual aspects within this strategy
and gives us the opportunity as
councillor st. has said if we were to
review and request a resubmit the
council at the county council who
ultimately owned this document this is
not as I've said before extra for
District Council document this is a
county council document that affects
Stratford district if we were this
requester of a review and a resubmit
they could accept that or they could
ignore it so I just want to put that
into your minds we could do that but
that doesn't necessarily mean it will
have the desired effect I will agree
that I think chairman I've said quite a
lot of there I I do think it's vitally
important that we bring this to fall
Council and have a full open debate I
hope my cabinet members support me in
that and I would put forward that we do
go to approve the recommendations being
put to Council thank you okay I think
Peter councilor riches has covered
issues fairly thoroughly I would like to
add one thing visibly the eastern relief
Road as I said earlier I understand from
the representations I've received that
there are a number of people that live
in older still in that part of Stratford
that do have concerns however I have
started to reply to some of the
responses I've had I haven't managed to
reply to them all but my line of
reasoning is that the eastern relief
road should be there not because I want
to intimidate people that live in what
they think is a rural quiet part of the
town a rural part part of the
countryside but we need to actually get
clever and long term make certain that
our major routes are some difference
away from our residential areas and
therefore the residential areas are
reserved by a good road network that's
not necessarily directly on top of them
and this will require some issues right
counts the Rope is pulling funny faces
at me but I'll explain what I mean later
but anyhow the situation is this that we
have presented before us today some
objections only one big objection from
within the cabinet but on the other hand
we know although he's not been possible
to get the detail to us that so the
scrutiny committee gave it a fairly
robust hearing last week and therefore
I'm going to suggest that we slightly
modify our proposal and recommendation
we look at the
recommendations to council on page 4
page 13 item 4 recommendation number one
has to stand otherwise our Constitution
will prohibit council from discussing it
and we've had a fairly lengthy
discussion with mr. Grafton over this so
I'm going to modify number two and say
despite the representations that have
been put forward cabinet recognizes that
the stratford-upon-avon area transport
strategy is written that as a potential
addendum to the warwickshire local
transport plan 2011 226
. my screen goes blank at the crucial
moment right given that context cabinet
recommends to council to consider the
strategy for endorsement
so in other words what we're doing is
we're not endorsing it this afternoon
but we're acknowledging that it's been
prepared with an objective in mind we
are allowing on the 24th of you're
looking at me a bit worried well we'll
read it out in the moment so the
situation is that on the 24th of April
there will be a full council meeting in
this chamber and we will have an item on
the agenda to consider and make a final
decision on this council's view to
present to Warwickshire County Council
yes counselor Jefferson cannot be
absolutely clear leader that I agree
wholeheartedly
you don't accountable can I just be
clear that if I support both motions I
am not considered to endorse tea well
I'm going to actually endorse my motion
if it's put and I don't wish to be
considered them endorsed it as such I
want to leave that to Council so what
have you written down Caroline
[Music]
despite the recommendation put forward
cabinet recognizes that I miss the next
bit so I was hoping you forward me your
email and then long so given the context
cabinet record recommends to Council to
consider the strategy for endorsement
yes saying the same so I think I think
ultimately it says the same thing I
don't like frankly I don't mind the
important thing is this needs to go to
full Council for a proper open debate we
I think we're all in agreement with that
that's right it's it's matter cerium we
are making to ensure it gets to Council
for that debate and they then make the
decision on behalf of the council or
themselves as to what their views should
be to present to the County Council I'm
getting nods everywhere but apart from
you piece you're looking at me a bit
bluntly but then why are you smiling at
me now that's pretty rare I don't smile
Chris right can you just confirm which
one of those recommendations we're going
to give him any context council is
recommended to consider the strategy for
endorsement is what I said didn't I
I think I'd like to stick to that
version right is there agreement to that
do I need a seconder oh well done please
or thank you right okay
proposed to second in agreed agreed
right that's the decision
yeah I'm actually home today so albury
worthy Council is requested
right moving on to item five
stratford-upon-avon market policy our
council riches will introduce this Thank
You chair I probably won't be much of an
introduction because it's quite a short
item I think and hope we've recently
reissued the new market contract this
report seeks to allow the portfolio
holder me and the executive director had
a paid service to make changes to the
market policy it makes a lot of sense
that we don't bring this back to cabinet
for any changes going forward small
administrative changes can be managed
with mr. Weber myself
that's it chair thinking Castlerock
insin yeah it's or isn't it but to me
it's a very good move as you probably
know I've always believed in preached
for some time management must manage and
this helps to go down that path and
actually in one of the national
newspaper by Sir John Timpson there's an
article very much on this same principle
so if I had a chance to vote I would be
in favor of it I think first centuries
counts are arkinson there have been
markets in Stratford town under the
various charters that have existed and
we do need a management scheme and I
don't think anything in this paper is
inhibiting that management to take place
right but there are two issues one is we
have to ensure that our policy in
Stratford doesn't encroach on Ulster
which is why I think the six and
two-thirds miles is mentioned and
secondly we have got a new operator that
we've appointed and we haven't formally
made any firm announcement of that until
this report so what we're asking cabinet
to do
is to allow the old rules of management
that have taken place for many years to
take place the officers to amend it to
manage it okay the new operator is now
identified and furthermore if suddenly
Big Brother the law of the land suddenly
says you've got to change your rules we
don't necessarily want another cabinet
player but to make small changes we
allow the chief officers involved or the
portfolio holders or both together
preferably in my book to actually make
those changes thanks for the explanation
wasn't necessary I quite understand what
the issues are God he's a clairvoyant as
well okay market policy so the
recommendation is that the market person
is agreed and we authorize whoever to
make relative administrative changes as
required by law or wider powers and
agreed thank you we then move on to the
proposed performance management
framework measures of monitoring
arrangements for 2018-19
counselor Thirlwall Thank You leader
this paper sets out the proposed
management framework for 2018 2019 based
on the final year of the current
corporate strategy it is made up of the
annual action plan as detailed in
Appendix 1 key performance indicators in
appendix 2 and finally district health
measures appendix 3 which concentrate on
the progress of lifespan of the
council's corporate strategy performance
monitoring will base current as reported
in section 3 of the report on page 74
therefore I asked a cabinet to one
approve the corporate strategy action
plans for the year for 2018 and 19
Appendix 1 excuse me to approve the key
performance indicators KPIs and target
appendix 2
to approve the district health measures
appendix three to approve the monitoring
arrangements it was set out in paragraph
three Thank You Jimmy any debate council
riches chairman as you know I'm really
really keen on KPIs and the management
of them the thing that I'm really not
keen on is key performance indicators
where would be a most measured against
other people's delivery so I think what
we should start to do is look deeper
into these KPIs and address whether or
not we can directly influence their
outcomes it's almost like having 100
meter sprinter time and him on how
quickly you can run but also whether
another Sun comes up you can influence
one but he can't influence the other so
I think there are certain kpi's that we
measure that we shouldn't be measuring
because we can't be accountable for the
outcome but other than that I'm
comfortable to report that just like us
to move forward into a more dynamic way
of measuring them now I approve of that
approach in as much as there are certain
things that we cannot control but they
are key to the success of our district
if something I'm happy to take away and
look T we can redefine and throughout
this year council most two brief points
Jerry first of all on target specified
points perfect
I think housing mix is becoming such an
important issue
it raises people's consciousness both
ESU children
with you the second is 89 second point
down the percentage increase in active
businesses from the base year and I'm
quite surprised chairman the latest year
we've got information on this 2013 it's
five years out of eight now we may have
taken that as the base state but I'm
surprised what to comment on those two
coin points first of all I can comment
on the housing mix I totally agreed with
your thoughts there and once again and
quite happy to take that away and see if
we can include it sooner than later for
the second point I might have to ask for
a more detailed explanation hopefully
from one of my colleagues German I think
going back to councillor Richie's points
in terms of what we've got control over
there was some difficulty in us coming
up with actual numbers on a regular
basis so what what the target area is
looking at the trend of information is
coming through in terms of jobs created
in job sites gargy what I'm not clear
about is whether the growth which is
based a some colonies you know as part
of the local enterprise partnership
whether they're still collecting that
level of data so maybe there we need to
have a conversation with them but it's
not something that we would routinely
report on because it picks up the wider
area
councillor Richards point if it's that
sort of I've controlled the measureless
and it's the most recent one we've got
is 2013 it doesn't seem to me to be an
appropriate measure councillor riches
yeah I agree
with just recently I'm not sure if
you've seen in your council of laws
we've just recently had a an economic
assessment carried out in conjunction
with the County Council there was quite
a few involved in that which has got
some really specific numbers in it so it
probably is that we have got a baseline
to work forward again it's not
measurable that we can directly
influence the outcome but I think we've
got some really specific numbers about
how businesses are formed and how
they're growing the district now can I
also comment on councillor mortis point
about housing mix he will remember that
he had put down a motion a council on
this and indeed if you look at the
forward plan but his included as a part
of a later item on today's agenda you'll
see that that motion is down for
consideration at the April cabinet
meeting and indeed mr. Weese has done
some research going back to 2011 which
I've seen in draft form and he's also
done some other collation of information
from the time we adopted our corporate
strategy core strategy back in July 2016
so we are collecting together the
information and therefore the matter if
we've got time for it should come back
to but we will make time for it at full
council in in April because the cabinet
meeting in April is before the 24th of
April council meeting
Gemini Gemini welcome thank you and I
was aware of them also welcome cancel
the farewells point that there are main
merit inclusion there's the more
specific target yeah the issue is not
being ignored
okay I don't think those questions give
rise to amendments to the
recommendations which are on page 73
four of them to approve the three
appendices plus the monitoring
arrangements which are listed in the
main report is that agreed
thank you right item seven member
development working group planning
training errors
counselor Thirlwall Thank You leader of
the meeting of the member developed
working group held on the 30th of
January 2018 the group considered the
reintroduction of the planning talk the
group felt that it would not only be
beneficial for new counselors in may
2000 19 but existing members the tool
would highlight examples of good and bad
practice and should be supported by
briefing session before and after the
event
accordingly I asked the cabinet to
accept the recommendation that the
planning tour for existing members be
scheduled for the summer of 2018 and
also for new counselors up to may 2019
the planet all would contribute to
members training hours thank you any
debates on that counselor Rich's only a
really quick one in that I totally agree
and this should contribute towards
training hours and it's really important
I just wonder whether or not this could
have been dealt with by the member
working member development working group
or yourself Steven with the portfolio
decision to create the training and made
them rather than company I kind of feel
like it's not a major issue for cabinet
I but I I appreciate that but the
rules of working turn at the moment say
any alteration to policy that we make on
playing hours has to be decided by the
covenant whether the leader wishes to
review that in the future I'm asking
them perhaps I'm asking maybe we should
take a wider view on that because I
don't think this is a huge issue for for
the executive personally and so maybe
that just bad might puff from that
really good idea let's do that right so
recommendations at the bottom of page 95
as counsel referral says is that agreed
great wake up can't hear you just have
to get the duty man out right
South militia Community Safety
Partnership priorities counselor
Jefferson thank you later
this report presents the community
safety priorities for 2018-19 as agreed
by the South Warwickshire Community
Safety Partnership board meeting on 28th
of January 2018 well to say that I
actually chaired that board the
priorities were actually agreed in the
light of the fact that crime rates are
now rising after a number of years where
they've been falling there has been some
confusion over this over the last two or
three years because of changes in
recording practice we had a very
thorough debate particularly on
anti-social behavior
crime in rural areas and drugs and we
had some excellent input from the place
so with that I would like to recommend
the proud so essentially we're being
asked to agree the diagram in paragraph
two or indeed any discussion any debate
nope right so the recommendation on page
97 is the warrior Community Safety
Partnership priorities be endorsed is
that agreed
co-op site fiery square suddely
councillor Richards Thank You chairman
of the public speaker on this I was
hoping to get a slightly less rough ride
over this one but I get the feeling I'm
not going to the report is fairly
self-explanatory we the co-op site as we
all know it's been a bit of a problem
site and steadily FIR whilst someone
suggested 15 years earlier in today
I think longer than that we had our most
recent conversation with a co-op has
suggested a very positive route forward
that the the site will be brought back
into an appropriate use sooner rather
than later I have discussed with our
Ward members for the cover that site and
they've both suggested suggested that
we've heard it all before
I think it's important to note that was
yes we have a timeline now from the coop
we always account the water taken the
decision to include 50,000 in our budget
to start CP o proceedings should that
timeline not be met so I think is very
important to note for everyone in the
room but particularly for cabinet
members making the decision today that
if this timeline isn't met then we will
begin those CPA proceedings Thank You
councillor house just a brief mention
from the OSC we discussed this at the
last meeting and we like everybody else
I think you're very skeptical about the
way that this thing has developed we
have asked that we receive a copy of the
recommendations that come forward from
the meeting with them on the 16th so
that we can look at it by the 23rd and
also ask whether or not if we're not
getting where we want to be whether the
cats are going to consider this as a
trigger point for the CPO
well you don't need my permission as to
how to deal with me yeah I would say do
you want a response to mr. Grafton no
well we are we are recommending that
this if we do not get what we want that
the trigger point will be that meeting
that we will go forward to the CPO I
think like I said the important thing to
note is we have that in our back back
pocket so to speak it's there and that
has been made traitor to the coop if we
don't hit the dates that they have put
to us then it is I have absolutely every
intention to press the button and start
that CPO process we in order to conduct
CPR we have to give every reasonable
opportunity for the coop to progress the
site they have a timeline if we start
that trigger before they breach their
timeline then we would be unsuccessful
the CPO if they breach the timeline then
we can start those proceedings and that
is why I tend to be I'm heartened by
your response
okay any other discussion on that right
then can I ask councilor sue red one to
come up please and address the cabinet
okay and I'm not quite certain
at what point you were talking about
pressing the button are you talking
about in April if certain things aren't
met because none of the things that I
wanted to say was I came here in March
2015 and at that point it was not a
cabinet sorry but to the planning
committee and spoke then that it had
been over 10 years since the first
enforcement's had been issued to to come
up and we were at that point no further
forward and they've been there had been
a number of plat pre-application
discussions and inquiries to both owners
and planning officers had revealed
references to discussions with various
interested developers and housing
associations but nothing concrete had
come from any of those decisions and
really that site is a prime location so
the question I asked at the time was
what
why is no sorry but nothing materializes
from these discussions is it because
that the coop themselves the owners are
unrealistic for unrealistic or
unachievable prices or developments on
the site at that time it was agreed to
recommend the Planning Committee agreed
to record recommend to cabinet that I
see
you know put forward as a possible
planning move but now three years down
the line we're still actually discussing
are we going to move forward you know
with it planning with an a compulsory
purchase order or not the timeline
that's in this that you are talking
about look sir
developers submitting bids in September
and by November two months later the
site would be sold detailed planning
obtained and the site redeveloped and
that two months doesn't even seem
possible to end it well that could
happen in two months the other thing I
want to say is that the and no tell you
that this the development of this site
is actually a priority by Stratford
district council to actually look at
this and deal with it so my concern is
that delaying doing anything until
November which is another eight months
down the line just doesn't seem the
right way forward to me and I just want
to let the cabinet know that the only
decision that Dudley parish fact council
feel is suitable is for Stratford
district council not to pause work on
developing a CPA but to run the looking
at and developing a compulsory purchase
order alongside your any work that the
coop are doing yes right I'll ask
councillor Richards if he respond to
that please
Thank You chair so you make some broad
points I don't propose to go through the
details of how CPI works but I can tell
you it is a the thresholds in order
to begin CPOE and to achieve seco are
enormous Lehigh and they take a huge
amount of time what's happened in the
past again I can't speak for I know
there has been a lot of work going on in
the past that would have prevented a
successful CPA we're now in a position
where we've collected enough evidence to
support us in that and we continue to
collect that evidence however we in
order for us to have a reasonable chance
of success at c-p-r we must allow this
timeline to progress if the coop do not
hit the deadlines that they have agreed
with us and we continue to work with
them as they're going through these
deadlines if they do not hit those that
is the moment at which point we start
our CPA process and so you have my
assurances on that that we will be doing
that if they don't meet those deadlines
if they do and we're quite happy for it
to carry on but it is a high priority
for us as you pointed out okay and can I
just ask one question
at which point in that timeline would I
mean would you be looking at the end of
April which is some of the earliest
points on if they haven't met the early
stages would you then be looking at
starting I'll be looking at soon as
physically possible on upon a breach
okay thank you very much okay right
counselor ikenson yeah just as a point
of information I am aware that the
authority took ncpo against the island
Kathy a few years back and the leader
then saw what a disgrace it was came in
got hold of the solicitor from your
predecessor and said put a compulsory
purchase order on he said never done it
before said find out and do it and I
think it was done within a week and the
whole situation resolved
right
counselor ridges and thank you for your
information and coming along so I had
something to do with this before Pete
was on the cabinet through his
predecessor we thought there was a
number of meetings and I guess the thing
that I picked up on the whole need to
reassure you about was he said that
nothing emerges from these discussions
and you know and while we talk about it
being high priority it doesn't seem to
be the case and that's not the reality
quite often with some of the work we do
the forward public face inside of it
doesn't become a paranoid looks like
it's fell over through bureaucracy or
rent table or whatever and the reality
is we went an awful long way down the
road with Stanford with priori square
previously with money coming from the
left as well to try and remediate the
road there was all sorts going on and
then it ultimately collapsed for a
number of reasons
personally I Pete now councillor
Richards now taking this forward he's
got a very similar approach to these
things as me in that we move it forward
no matter what happens so I would see
great comfort in the fact that we're all
very committed to making this site
happen if they start collapsing on the
deal again then we've got the power to
force their hand I think that the
regulations over sepia have just been
slightly relaxed and they're all there
imminently about to be relaxed all the
process that we've got to go through I'm
sure I read something about the other
day but regardless were very very
committed to and there's money to one
side for a new Cancer Research thank you
for that counsel Richie's I mean you're
actually right I am this is a high
priority there's a lot of work has gone
on behind the scenes before and if I
want to see this think that was properly
and as as expediently as possible the
cpo rules
I understand require a scheme so to
compare the this site with the site that
cancer that concerns just referred to I
think it would be incorrect
if things don't happen within a week as
you've probably noticed
but we will put every bit of strength
behind it my officers will tell you how
much of a pain I can be batter and their
deadlines so I can assure you we're on
top okay right then so consequently we
have a recommendation on page hundred
and one the proposed course of action
set out within the report is endorsed I
had spotted you with your hand up I do
apologize in some ways I simply want to
reiterate what sue Redmond has said but
I've been living with this site now for
16 years the first two years are
believed everything the co-op said I
believe word the word but it was all
gonna happen and develop her after
developer shook my hand and assured me
that this was going to happen and I
think on the whole they would probably
honest men but actually nothing happened
and so it goes on and what are basically
the Qantas it is what I've already
written down but it's embedded into the
corporate strategy that it will go
through and is embedded into the core
strategy but it will go through now
those are promises because counsel which
assures us will be honored
first I have sat in cabinet meetings I'm
sorry
and before we actually had a such a
thing as a cabinet I've sat in meetings
being assured that he was all going to
happen so really and truly I would like
much stronger words then we're being
used at that at the moment I don't mind
how you strengthen it that commitment
towards Studley and that site because
it's not just about studly
site it's about the district itself more
cars and lorries go past that site and
come to Stratford they go off down to
the a46 or they go down to the Junction
9 of the motorway they do not come to
Stratford and what that site is telling
them that's what Stratford looks like
and the other thing I would like to ask
as well is when something does
eventually go forward is that there is
some consultant consultation with the
with the residents in the district
because I I don't know if anybody can
remember all the previous plans that
have come forward for that site but we
were building slums number two for the
future and that's something I would like
to be looked at and cared for very
carefully I think it's important that
the residents are included after having
felt as if they've been neglected for
many years over this issue that's
fundamentally what I want and asking for
you you have a very different-looking
cabinet now from the ones you've
referred to before this is a young
dynamic proactive
but make sure you get that comment
please yes you've had an open commitment
in this meeting with from me that this
is gonna move forward yes the rest of
the cabinet members wouldn't be
supporting this if they didn't agree
with that commitment I think you can
take it away as a win right okay for
real this time
real show me show me
we've made that amendment more more
assurance do you need okay thank you
and the other thing is it's not just me
saying there will be an scrutiny
committee said it as well I think it's
important that we do get to report to
the overview and scrutiny committee keep
an eye on and that I think it would be
halfway through really the timeline that
they've actually put this act simply
report there yeah was that a question or
you're looking at me as if you want me
to respond I mean did with the throw
that proposed or I'm quite happy for
them to be updated I think we'll take
this outside but I mean probably the
most appropriate thing would be to do
every time there's a deadline to inform
us see that there's been here or no it's
not that start proceedings okay
have I missed anybody else out now thank
you
we we don't often get praise for
something that takes so long I was just
thinking while counselor Wright was
speaking now I can remember one council
meeting a certain young girl from studly
high school came and stood down there at
the back of the meeting and invited me
to take some action and I did agree
councils kerogen right we'll both been
in the room at the time would have heard
me say so but it's taken a long time and
we've now got to use if you like a bit
of browbeating tactics a bit of pressure
tactics in order to get things moving so
anyhow so Niihau but so the issue is
that we have got on now that young girl
I was told because her mother works here
is now University Hey
right well we won't take that any
argument any further just in case I get
myself into trouble and we will now move
as I said a moment ago to the
recommendation on page 101 but first
course of action set out in the report
is endorsed I would say the proposed
cause of action as confirmed by
councilor Richards's indoors so agreed
agreed we thank you
right provision to empty property
assistance grant also councillor
Richards I don't think there's any
public speaking on this which the
slow-release so this is okay great so as
this as place says it's off the other
reporters about the empty homes at the
MS property assistance grant we've
offered this for quite some times twenty
thousand pounds to bring in an empty
property back into use in so doing the
council
are able to get a nomination rights on
those properties at the moment we're
able to get a nomination rights for up
to five years I'm very pleased to say
that in all the cases that where this
has been used those tenants that have
been put into the tents come from our
home choice plus system those that have
been put into these homes have not only
met there five years but also continue
to be potent in no times which is so
fantastic new story forum for the
district and the council what we're now
seeking to do is to give some form of
flexibility to increase the take-up of
this this is grant so the report sets
out the exploration of having a
three-year grant period a set through a
year or the possibility of having a
five-year term with the potential for
early termination by the property owner
and if the property owner words of
terminate early they would then be
required to pay back an agreed sum to
the council from that grant and
appropriate some there have been changes
to the recommendations through
consultation with our legal offices my
head of service and monetary officer the
recommendations should now read that the
cabinet supports amending the empty
property assistance grant scheme offered
under the record the regulatory reform
order 2002 to allow one the early
termination of nomination rights in
return for the repayment of an
equivalent proportion of the awarded
grant and to the option of awarding an
empty property assistant grant with a
nomination rights for a period of
between five and three years I will
leave that for to be able to chair thank
you dance the house can I support Tony
or holder what the position is with
regard to business premises being
converted to private use to get the
I don't so my understanding is they
don't apply I'm going to look to my head
of service to answer that fully showing
thank you the moment that scheme is
drafted only applies to empty dwellings
it doesn't apply to business properties
but members may also be aware that the
flexibilities in the planning regime
allow certain office based businesses to
be converted to residential through
planning anyway but not necessarily with
with or without any financial incentives
so the result already a kind of
incentive to help people return
businesses into within the scope of the
scheme proposed to include them at this
time
I think that's a very good point and
certainly I'd be happy to consider a
mechanism in which we could do that I
don't think it would form part of this
but I think potentially a a similar
mechanism that separate from this would
be appropriate I'll take that away and
discuss with my head of service the best
way we can we can bring that forward I
think the main interest here was to look
at housing to get the council tax in
from it and also we got a bonus on our
new homes bonus as well so far for
converting these houses back into
habitable use that's the financial
advantage that the council had right
there was hands up over here was it
councillor riches all right it was a
frivolous intervention right Cass
Watkinson oh I answered the question
before you answer okay right then now
the recommendations before us are not
the ones in the report they're the ones
that councillor Richards read out but we
happy to support those that agree agreed
agreed
right thank you next item which I will
have to take now because council organs
still on on holiday and
capital budget monitoring now the
paperwork has been presented it contains
no surprises it lists the capital budget
monitoring as per the original budget in
February 2017 modifications on the 10th
of April 5th of June and therefore we
get an amended figure and how that is
being depleted and spent is listed in
the various appendices any questions
that mr. Buckland will answer no right
then the recommendation is the position
on capital expenditure and income from
period one to ten is received and we
would didn't identify any further
consider any further issues so we just
stopped received till grade three and
the heights of twelve revenue budget
monitoring and we've got a variance of
period ten and we've got a long list of
how that variance is made up on pages
124 and 125 we're getting near the end
of the financial year
therefore these that these lists are
longer and
we have an outer revenue reserved
position and as I say are there any
issues there off street parking shows a
favorable balance of one hundred and
fifty thousand hundred fifty seven
thousand five hundred and nineteen can
anyone remember the last time we put up
the parking charges it's sometime
obviously our car parks must be
attractive with severe potential users
Jimmy like quite a lot of address
comments about the county's parking
charges I think that what you put up the
pub the challenges from the county for
on street have gone up quite falling pin
so number of adverse comments from
people about that which is a very
difficult to handle what control do you
think we have
but people are commented to me that they
think it was deliberate so that people
were putting more money than the 55 P
and not get any change out people are
skeptical right is that what it is but
when they use our car park machines they
don't have the odd 5 P problem right
okay so again recommendation on page 123
variance of period 10 oh sorry I'm sorry
chairman and I wish to comment on the
reserves I'm almost embarrassed to
raises again chairman but only almost on
page 126 I turn estimated revenue
reserves at the 31st of March 8 point 8
million when the budget papers were
presented to us chairman that estimated
position was half a million pounds lower
four hundred and seventy three thousand
dollar to be precise I merely wondered
if we could be told is that permanent
increase or are we expecting that to
reverse next year well I'm for mr.
Buckland to answer Thank You leader
yeah the position that was reported to
the governor and council to in February
was the position is at the end of period
eight now updated there the forecast to
the end of period ten
I will bring attention to paragraph four
point one point three within the report
now within that particular section
there's three items add a variance two
of which I would strongly suspect will
result in slippage around three hundred
and forty five thousand at year-end
therefore taking the count on most of
the the majority of the additional
position on reserves that comes from
waters identified okay
right why missed anybody out it's a plus
three is about time we were finishing
right recommendation on page one two
three variants a period ten and the
estimated revenue our turn is received .
we haven't addressed any further issues
okay so agreed right now moving on the
next item item 13 is the forward plan
which was published on Friday the
cabinet work program but that and the
minutes from the policy advisory group
the member development working group are
all on block items and nobody's they've
requested they'd be pulled out apart
from the issue over planning training
and therefore I must ask you to support
those three items on block to note them
agreed and then find the urgent business
mr. Weber never too busy scanning right
there's no urgent business next meeting
of the cabinet 9th of April and I
declare the meeting closed thank you